this week jules and i sit down and
discuss the shootings in america boys
and men remote work
and independent politics all of that
this week on forward
[Music]
welcome back it's andrew and jules you
thought that i had disappeared but i am
here jules and i were just having a
conversation about reading books i'm
developing quite a book collection i
don't know if you all have noticed but i
interview authors a lot and i buy their
books and i buy a hard copy of the book
so it turns out that
boys and girls read fiction but then
after you get to adulthood apparently
men consume much less fiction we kind of
switch to non-fiction whereas women
still you read both fiction and
non-fiction so i guess this means that
women have broader reading tastes um but
i was reflecting on the fact that when i
was young i used to read science fiction
and fantasy novels like
candy like i just you know would inhale
them and then now i read tons and tons
of non-fiction uh so i was just talking
to zach who's also here we could get
zach in as our third third remember the
tripod zach was like yeah that tracks
that's his experience too so i don't
know what that says about men and women
but apparently our reading tastes
diverge at a certain point i think it's
like for example science fiction yeah
everyone kind of taps into that when
they're younger it's more so and then
men kind of tap out of that genre as
they grow older and i think it's more so
like these things are very maybe
imaginative and maybe like romanticizing
different things of life and i think
girls especially like in their adulthood
still tend to
flock to that and then guys yeah end up
going to like you're saying non-fiction
round of kind of just hard facts and
kind of lose that imaginative and create
what does that say about it yeah look at
this creature like these are
imaginations it's like going to these
like dystopian novels uh yeah i took a
pop culture in the us class in college
and
we were assigned romance novels
they said a box by myself said grab one
and so i read it and it was great
so now i understand romance novels as a
four because i read one and uh you know
it was like escapist fantasy it was good
fun
well it's also interesting that that
girls end up going to like those uh like
murder podcasts a lot of the times like
it's known that those types of podcasts
are very female dominated in terms of
the audience but also what does that say
because like that's not necessarily
fiction but it is like the storytelling
of like these extremes true crime yeah
that's just true crime is the word yeah
i did know that women consumed true
crime podcasts at a much higher level
yeah i i find that fascinating too and i
think it's more so maybe
just kind of internalizing almost like
this fear that woman or maybe it's maybe
it's relationships because there is
always a drama involved with the true
crime stuff right yeah i remember
growing up i watched a lot of like
criminal minds and everything like that
and found that stuff fascinating and
like especially when you're growing up
like you do very much internalize those
storylines i remember like i would walk
past a window at night and i'd be like
oh my god like i would think something's
gonna like pop out all the time
yes you know i i do think that the
majority of the audience's podcast is is
men
i i think that checks out numerically
this week i feel like
so many things came up that really
reminded me of the pages of the war on
normal people as well as forward just so
many different tendencies and um just
yeah cultural situations that you talked
about on the pages of these books not
that you were necessarily predicting
them but more so noticing the emergence
of them and i think it's important to
talk about yeah as we talk about the
relationship with men and different
things was these different shootings
that happened over the past weekend two
of them were considered like mass
shootings one of them was much bigger so
there was on sunday it was a church in
california
um i think it was like two killed five
injured in milwaukee when the bucks game
was happening there were three different
shootings one of those shootings was
responsible for 17 injured and then
biggest one that the media had really
ran with as well was the buffalo buffalo
new york times was the first
of these three over the weekend and that
dealt with an 18 year old male that
there was no doubt that it was racially
motivated because he detailed um
his plan in a manifesto um 10 killed
three wounded live streamed on twitch
just a pure evil situation pure evil um
you can't like i would don't seek this
out i don't believe so i don't even
think you can really access the
manifesto on social media
yeah so what were your initial thoughts
when seeing this news because you know
you're very passionate about this boys
and men conversation and i would just
love to hear your take on that yeah it's
heartbreaking you think about people
shopping and living their lives and then
having this
evil
lunatic
yeah teenager come and take so many
lives brutally and senselessly
uh so we're we're at a point in american
life and it's start it's super dark
because we all are at this point where
you see there's news about a shooting
and then you ask okay
what kind of shooting is it yeah like
like what's the nature of the shooter
the nature of the victims and a lot of
that hinges on race
now in the buffalo shooting crystal
clarets hate crime uh white supremacist
manifesto
really disgusting i can't imagine
victimizing that neighborhood in buffalo
and seeing those people as
somehow your enemy mean that the entire
thing is beyond dark it it truly is evil
the other shootings i i'll say one of
them actually strikes quite close to
home where the
church shooting in california is of a
taiwanese american community and the
gunman was a 68 year old chinese
american who drove from las vegas and
apparently had been ingesting propaganda
about
taiwan and got angry enough where he
drove across very targeted yeah state
lines is targeted
milwaukee shootings uh it struck me from
the news accounts i read that it seemed
like there was some kind of like gang
violence against
probably members of another gang yeah it
seemed like there was like multiple yeah
guns involved everything like that yeah
so so when i was looking at
these three
and
i i think the attention is rightfully
being placed on the buffalo shooting
because one of one of them is i think it
did happen first chronologically so our
attention went to that but the the white
supremacist
shooter is unfortunately becoming a
trope or a pattern
that people are seizing on and saying
uh you know that this is evil and
probably
not isolated in the sense that it's
happened before or will likely happen
again and so people are rightfully
trying to figure out how we can stop it
there's been communication and this is
another dark thing about american life
is that people have given up on even
talking about gun control as a practical
solution because everyone knows that
you're not gonna be able to pass it
uh and so now we're focusing on the
messaging yes and and i do think that
there's this online radicalization
phenomenon that is dark consistent uh
going to get worse and
needs to be
focused on to try and
put a stop to it
so i'm on board there and you know
because of the fact that like i have
been writing about this stuff since 2018
like i this this stuff scared the [ __ ]
out of me
uh
for years um and when we had barbara
walter
the author of the next civil war
on uh she said there are 400 militias in
the u.s the 80 of them are all right
anti-government white nationalist so
that this is the very very virulent
growing strain of hate and american life
and there are these trends they're all
layered on top of each other so i talk
about boys and men and a bunch which i
do think it's related yeah you have the
this disintegration there's a clear
trend of who is
moving forward with these types of acts
well over 95 percent of the shooters are
clearly boys or men
so that that's the macro context and
then the micro is what happens
in the brain of this particular
uh 18 year old that radicalizes him and
when it comes to online radicalization
and you know those conversations of free
speech and kind of where is the line of
people just critiquing certain mindsets
and certain ideologies and such and
where it's kind of do you feel like the
line is and where social media companies
or other
organizations need to step in when it
comes to this online radicalization
i think there are very very distinct
cesspools i haven't personally you know
gone digging yeah deep into them yeah
you know but you know what they are it's
like 4chan 8chan and some of these
others and so i think that's where you
start because i think that that's like
the most
virulent dark
evil hateful material
um that actively tries to radicalize you
you know that's like
that shows you certain videos like you
know there'd be this person literally
had a camera on his
head because he wanted to share it and
so i that that's where you start like
the darkest recesses of the internet
want to talk to you guys about a new
sponsor we have called air table and if
you've ever tried to do any sort of
leadership activity or startup you have
seen airtable at least be offered to you
as an awesome solution in this ever
changing landscape of work how can you
ensure your people workflows and data
stay connected airtable is how airtable
allows you to create flexible systems
that help your team operate as one i've
used it a few times different orgs and
it's fantastic so break down the
barriers that leave teams feeling
disconnected with airtable your team
works from a single source of truth that
is always up to date and keeps everyone
on the same page so with their adaptable
approach everyone from marketers to
product teams to podcast producers can
build tools that fit uniquely to the way
they work plus airtable keeps individual
projects connected to your higher level
goals so you never lose sight of what
you're working toward it's pretty
awesome so give it a try for free at
airtable.com today that's airtable.com
to get started for free check it out
guys a massively helpful tool
[Music]
there was a video of you from a
democratic debate that was resurfacing
after this happened and you said we have
to find ways to turn our boys into
healthy strong men who do not hate but
feel like they have paths forward in
today's economy it's clear that a lot of
uh boys and men today don't necessarily
feel that path being there and you know
while there is an array of cultural
reasoning an easy yet wrongful route is
to typically go at other normal people
um different groups of normal people and
that's what we're seeing so what do you
see as like the key paths that we need
to target first other than online
radicalization i mean i think the single
biggest variable if you and i haven't
looked into this particular
shooter but
one pattern is that they don't have
fathers in the household like if you
have a father in the household i think
the odds of you are heading down certain
roads
drops a ton for sure now again you can't
go back in time and give this
you know
person a
two-parent household but i i think
that's the single biggest variable and
one of the things i talked about on the
war on normal people is that 41 42 of
american children are born
to
unmarried moms today single moms
outnumber
single fathers
something like four or five to one
so you have a lot of little boys who are
brought up being brought up by single
moms
and
i think it's tough for that boy to
develop positive role models or a sense
of masculinity and then if they get
drawn to an online rabbit hole
that
says like this is how you discover a
sense of importance or identity it's
much easier for them to to fall
prey to that kind of hateful thinking if
they don't have someone in the house
being like hey let's go outside and
throw a football around and like dude
you know you don't have someone
in the house that can show you a better
way you can
try and channel your energies positively
i think it's important to also talk
about
how important a foundation of a family
is for these individuals too not only
just kids but also
like being able to provide that to a kid
with this new generation that's coming
up and is having these issues
what like how do you see the importance
of family just as an adult and like how
important that also was has been in your
life as a parent with someone else in
the household yeah so this is one of the
the tough things is when i've talked
about two-parent households than certain
people online are like hey you're
somehow judging folks who are in
different situations and i'm a thousand
percent not like i think that single
moms are freaking super human single
parents are superhuman but i
feel that because i think parenting is
super difficult there are two of us it's
still hard i have no idea how anyone
would do it
alone yep um
and so
that's been my experience it actually is
one of the things that drove me to run
for president i talked about in the book
because when i became a parent
it nearly
uh
tore my
mind soul heart apart like so much
stress in the household
uh i thought that it would be okay and
it was not okay it turns out that our
son was autistic and my wife had picked
up on that
on some instinctive level and i did not
because you know like you're first-time
parent and so so our conversations were
often around i'll give you an example
like christopher
when he woke up he would just start
screaming and then when we had another
child and he was not screaming as soon
as he woke up i was like oh my gosh like
you know i kind of thought that maybe
there's a difference yeah i mean maybe
screaming was not the usual
like greeting of the day yeah yeah
so
so christopher 2 it's like if he were to
step from um let's say
grass to the concrete would start
freaking out about the texture change uh
you know and
so
when
you're a first-time parent and your
two-year-old is like you know
freaking out about something that seems
stupid
like do you think like oh this person's
like autistic like you know you don't
know better i mean i didn't know better
so there's just like a lot of
uh difficulty and stress and
it
very much tested um
my marriage where where like you know
evil and i were both very very stressed
out and so you know you're not
exactly your best self all the time to
your partner so i i imagined being
let's say even a couple maybe you're not
married but you're trying to make it
work
like that stress would break out most of
most of those couples you imagine trying
to bring up that child individually um
so i can see all these things falling
through the cracks
and i imagined
tens of millions of american families in
that situation imagine
the hardship
and the heartbreak because you want to
do your best for your
children and
a lot of cases you're not going to be
able to to do everything that the child
needs even if you do your best
through no fault of your own it's just
the era we're in and whether you're in a
single uh parent home or a two-parent
home with the internet now that's like a
whole another parent involved in terms
of like you a lot of the times you don't
know what your kid is exploring on the
internet you know you can have these
different settings or whatever but kind
of keeping track of that world as well
and what your kid is getting into you
know parents in past decades have a
little bit more control of like totally
yeah we know who you're hanging out with
we know who your teachers are parents
don't necessarily know how to navigate
it's this hard disconnected too of just
like a digital divide that's not just
amongst youth it's a digital divide
amongst generations of how kids are
using it versus how parents use it like
i think i'm more savvy than
for sure many parents and i would say i
don't have a clue of a lot of the stuff
that's going on yeah i do know that it's
worse for teenage girls by the numbers
in terms of mental health uh anxiety and
depression we talk about the failure of
boys and men but you know i mean
everyone has it tough nowadays in large
part because of social media and like
like we're talking about you're
rightfully passionate about voicing that
all the boys are not all right today and
not in a way that's like
right off half of society that
men make up 50
of society but in a way that's like hey
there's clear and valid reasoning for
this so how do you feel we need to pivot
dialogue around the issue so that it's
not demeaning or it's not pitying them
but it's also not being dismissive of
this issue and that it needs to be
tackled
one of the things that i'm
passionate about is to say look healthy
boys and men helps everybody yep
successful healthy
uh girls and women helps everybody you
know it's like like thinking that
there's some kind of strange zero-sum
game between the genders is
dumb and ridiculous and for boys and men
and in particular um white boys and men
um just no one wants to treat them as uh
like people who need help you know what
i mean like that they're always
the problem
and
you know it's like i don't think that's
fair because
i you know like that like life's
not peaches and cream for people of any
you know background particularly
now
so
those are a couple of the the things
that i'd
suggest is like you know everyone's
human like we should treat everyone as
if they
could use a hand if uh if they
need one yeah i don't get people don't
want to feel pitied i know if i ever
feel pitied whether it's like woman
messaging i'm like i i don't want to be
put in a box of like this limiting
situation of oh all men are experiencing
this so it is limiting in today's
society but there was actually a reply
to one of your tweets recently about the
situation and drew hall said we should
be telling every child heading into
puberty that they will have incredibly
violent thoughts and emotions that are
incredibly powerful and that you don't
necessarily know how to handle and after
we acknowledge these parts of our brains
growing we can offer healthy outlets and
counseling to manage these growing pains
in our mental health i think right now
amongst young boys that's looked at as
something that is a negative and a weak
part of their minds in reality it's like
it's natural
and
help giving them the tools of how to
deal with it like you said in a healthy
way in a strong way in your washington
post op-ed about this too i found this
line really interesting of male
dysfunction tends to take on an air of
nihilism and dropping out a society we
don't provide many avenues for healthy
recovery i think right now like we saw
that it was an 18 year old boy that did
the incident in buffalo new york but
there is a conversation of of course
just adult men in general whether you're
first navigating autonomy as a young
adult whether you're newly divorced
whether you just got fired from a job
and it's just a new sense of autonomy
the frustration of this time
it makes it easier to induce anger so
what do you see as avenues for healthy
recovery for adult men well one of the
stats in the war on normal people that
stuck with me is that unemployed men
volunteer in their community less than
employment even though you have much
more time on your hands and it's because
you don't feel valuable and so you don't
think oh i don't have a job like you
know maybe i'll go go to the
youth center or the church or whatnot
and lend a hand like you just think like
oh i'm gonna keep to myself
i think that's very normal for men and
so the question is
how can you
make people feel valued have them feel
like that they can
plug in in a way that um
that contributes and do it in a way that
is not shameful as you're describing
it's like it's actually like prized and
important and i think in that washington
post open i talk about like men need to
be valued or need to be needed or
something like that so in an ideal world
you'd have someone
call that
guy
and say hey i need a hand on something
and then you'd be like okay and you know
what is that project
it's it's a bit like the end of
shawshank redemption i don't know if
you've seen that movie yes it's like my
favorite movie you had to watch in
psychology class in high school
so you know when at the end you know he
goes to morgan freeman's character it's
like hey i could use a hand with this
like everyone just wants to get that
call saying i could use a hand with this
the question is who's
making that call and then what are the
projects that
someone needs help with they could be
volunteering in a certain capacity
right now one of the things that also is
tied up with mail value is some kind of
income or money
and so if if you get a call
saying hey like i need you to help me
with something and it doesn't pay then
you feel like you can only do it for a
short period of time and then you need
to find something that does pay
those points actually bring up an
interesting conversation about the
future of work because whenever i had
like restaurant jobs or whenever i had
you know was working at a gym i never
necessarily felt
this specific feeling i had until a
corporate job where you're you know very
stuck into these time constraints and
you're very just a salary job more so
of oh i wish i could just have all the
time in the world and with all that time
i would do this and then i got into a
situation where i was more self-employed
and you kind of have a more open
schedule where it's like yeah like you
are in control of this but i did find it
almost like yeah debilitating as like
you think you're going to do so much
with all this open time but i found it
became so important for me to have these
structures were actually vital but if
you would have right out of college told
me that i'd be like no like if i had all
the time in the world i would do this
long list of things and it is
interesting because i think a lot of
kids feel like this right now especially
college graduates that are having these
first full-time jobs yeah i mean i just
use my own experience where i tried to
start a company in my mid-20s totally
flopped
but it was it was miserable in part
because i didn't have an office so i was
working ineffectively and futilely
from home in isolated fashion
and i said to myself like i'm not going
to do that again you know it's like i i
at a minimum have to have some have some
place to go and then the next number of
jobs i had were these startups and i was
in the office and i did learn a few
things
and then when i became head of my own
company
i
made it a point to show up and be
diligent and
and i tried to look out for people and
be a good manager and take people out to
lunch and things like that and it's like
the
that sort of thing was important to me
the the tough part jules is that i think
80 percent of people you give them a
choice they're not going to want to go
to the office because why would you you
know
but the the question is
what
would you have gotten out of being in an
office three or four days a week you
know you might think oh this commute
sucks or no office culture's annoying
but that there are some virtues to it
and so if a young person's in a
situation where you're not getting that
uh you know i'd like to see them get
that in other ways if it's possible so
the first thing that came to mind and
this might not be useful but so there's
like a west point
uh model of leadership training
where they put cadets in charge of
someone in the class below them and they
also have them report to someone in a
class above them oh yeah so you have
different leadership experiences both up
and down all the time i think that's
very useful and it can be in any context
so i'm imagining that if you aren't
participating in an office environment
maybe you join a rock climbing gym or
like some activity where there's like a
development path there are people better
than you
maybe you're better than some other
people i think that kind of
context is super helpful and and
thinking of the future of work and how
our relationships with work are going to
change people are saying you know
whether it's 2015 humans might not even
have to necessarily do a lot of the work
that we do today of 2040 even
how do you feel like what are the types
of things that can be in place for
people's structure do you ever think
about that i do think about it a fair
amount yeah you know it's like so some
of the
ideas i i
have around this are that so right now
most of all of us work because we need
uh an income we need to survive et
cetera et cetera as you all know i mean
i i ran for president on this idea that
ai is going to do a lot of those jobs
yeah so you definitely thought about it
yeah i'm going to suggest that the work
from home
trend is going to accelerate the
automation of a lot of jobs because
like you know you're halfway there
you're like disembodied this is the
humanity of it of not yeah seeing people
in person yeah yeah so the the question
is what's the transition
and this is one reason why and one of
the things people said to me all the
time is like oh you know jobs aren't
about money and i was like i totally
agree you know like like we should be
looking to develop new forms of
community structure purpose
uh development fulfillment uh and if
it's not an office which i i'm cool with
and like you know it's like then what is
it going to be yep and that is the major
gap in american life right now
i interviewed arthur brooks the author a
while ago then he talked about humans as
being worshipful
and organized religion is fading as a
central component in people's lives and
community
and it's being replaced by media and
politics and he said that the
tv networks for example are media
tribes or cults or whatever you want to
call them and that the anchors are like
the new
idols
it was an interesting
argument and you can take it you know
not as far or as far as you want but
that there is certainly a void in
american life the job has been the
foundation of it for a long time not
just in terms of our incomes but also
our social life remember when i started
a job and i was only a liar for five
months but like you showed up and there
were peers and maybe you know you might
be attracted to someone you worked with
like there might be like your job could
be like
80 of your life yeah in politics it
tends to be
a hundred percent because you know
you're just doing it and you're
traveling and if someone's not with you
on the campaign and you don't have time
for them that sort of thing
that void in my opinion will be filled
by by something
um
we don't like
uh if we don't fill it with something
positive
now what does that positive version look
like i know it it could be
people starting new kinds of
community orgs or associations
i'm i interviewed a woman who's to come
out the podcast soon
i started a hybrid newsletter
event group in seattle called the
evergray uh you know i think that there
there is a real need
right now the problem is that the
economics aren't there in most of these
instances it's you know i mean this is
one of the biggest things i i think
about though yeah is that like how do
you fill this void
me and my friends the other week we're
actually talking about this just the
conversation about like we missed
misorganized sports and on the way as an
adult you know you can go play pickup
games and all this stuff like i played
volleyball growing up but there isn't
that like camaraderie around practices
which i find like the most fun part like
if in the future that could become a
normal for situation for adults because
it's always sad at the end of high
school when yeah like that feels like
it's a done chapter for you
totally yeah
i love that there are a couple of things
that formed
those experiences
um one of them is
summer camp
and i think we could all use more camp
in our lives oh for sure and when
there's been like an adult version of
camp sort of cheesy but also really
really infectious and fun and important
the next thing would be some kind of
organized sports
during my 20s and 30s i played a weekly
game of basketball with the same 15
guys yep and it was the high point of my
week no matter what else happened that
week could be like you know i'm just
gonna go
to that gym and play basketball it was
funny as i played with those guys for
years i have no idea what any of them
did for a living yeah it's just like
this cool relationship of it's it's
surface level but not in a bad way like
it's just like all positive yeah you
might get into some arguments but it's
it's just like so positive yeah and so
and so in my case too it was guys so it
was so broly you just show up and be
like sup sup yeah you know
just do your thing
and
it you know just made everything better
[Music]
you often make the case that many of our
problems though seemingly like beast on
their own are actually very
interconnected everything that we were
just talking about is somehow
interconnected when we're talking about
boys and men it can lead into education
it does lead into work a lot of the
times so
i would pinpoint polarization right now
as a clear initial push in a greater
domino effect i feel like you feel the
same though you can add more and like
what do you classify as the main drivers
of polarization right now well you know
i go into it in my book and just right
now polarization is profitable
polarization
is politically wise polarization
is the winning strategy so
you're going to expect more of it
because
you know everyone wins on it
you know i tend to think about the
numbers behind it i mean you have
multiple billion dollar media
organizations that separate us into
ideological camps and give us what we
want and get us angry at the other side
then you have trillion dollar social
media companies pouring gasoline on the
whole thing so this is going to get
worse and worse and not better the
question is can we break out of it in
time i think we've got a chance at it
happily because the current
party system is so
decrepit and
unrepresentative but you know it's a
very tall order it's a challenging task
well this week i saw two tweets that i
was happy to see
one whether you like either of these
guys or not one was from tim urban and
another was from elon musk in response
to him so tim urban did a five-part
thread i'll read the first two because i
think they're very fascinating to this
conversation and i agree so it was some
mantras for political thinking truth is
hard humility is hard independent
thinking is hard resisting tribalism is
hard over and over you will forget that
these things are hard and that's
probably when you'll fail at them and
like you're saying we see like people
are winning through playing into
polarization so it feels like yeah this
big win to me it's like an easy route
and it's kind of weak to play into that
but anyway part two of the thread
he goes bullies come in many forms stand
up to bullies and don't be a bully
political parties are big lame
corporations they're not worth your
identity
angels and demons are a delusion
everyone is flawed and everyone is
complicated courage is criticizing your
in-group i really and there's three
other tweets in that thread but those
two specifically regarding independent
politics i found
perfect perfectly stated perfectly
stated
better myself yeah seriously and then
elon replied he said
the whole notion of being left wing or
right wing is silly almost no one
initially agrees with the semi-random
collection of policies associated with
each wing they only support those
policies after they join the left or
right mind tribe so yeah a lot of people
whether they are you know feel like they
are 100 on to one side
couldn't name all of the policies under
a party it is genuinely just a tribe and
an energy around something that you
flock to in every situation
it's pretty crazy
it's it's crazy yet it's very very human
i mean if you buy that humans are
naturally tribal creatures which we are
yeah uh and then there are all these
social rewards around joining particular
tribes one of the best books around this
is the righteous mind by jonathan height
have you read that book i haven't but
you interviewed him i did yeah and so
this book explained so much to me and
many many other people he identified six
universal human values that cross every
culture
every society
caring
fairness
liberty
loyalty
authority
and sanctity
and he observed and this is where it
gets fascinating okay is that liberals
home in on the first two values caring
and fairness
and conservatives home in on the last
three loyalty authority and sanctity so
you have different people who are just
much more responsive to different values
uh different
notes or tones
liberty gets construed differently and
for both parties so we can leave it out
for a minute libertarian is probably
very happy being like yeah we get our
own value
but it gets distributed in different
ways yeah so as an example when we talk
about the border
uh liberals or talk about the treatment
of the migrants that's like caring and
fairness and then conservatives are like
why they're breaking the law it's like
loyalty authority sanctity so you have
different people and also height
observes that a slightly bigger
proportion
of people
are conservative and naturally respond
to those values and the psychological
makeup
it actually maps to certain qualities
that we have appetite for novelty
and your disgust reflex
if you're someone who just likes to try
new things and have new experience all
the time you're naturally more liberal
if you have
a high disgust reflex you are naturally
more conservative
uh if you you know like
think things are like unclean or germy
or something along those lines so those
are just you know traits that
personality that you have when you're
born
you know it turns out that a
very significant proportion of political
beliefs are genetic
in relationship
so
this is one reason why
when you talk about hating certain
people for
certain beliefs to me it really doesn't
make much sense because it's like wait i
thought i'm like one of the things i'm
supposed to not do is like hate people
for things they don't have any control
over and if it turns out your political
beliefs have a significant genetic
element then i can't hate you for your
politics because you know you probably
you know have like a naturally like
like high or low appetite for novelty or
disgust reflex or
uh threat sensitivity is another
psychological quality if you have high
threat sensitivity you tend to be
more conservative
so this is all to say that um when you
have folks like tim urban and and elon
and so here's where it gets sticky yeah
jules okay is that um uh so if you buy
this that you have uh
you that humans are innately tribal and
that
uh certain people respond to certain
values
more naturally than others what i
concluded
rightly or wrongly
is that
there is like a tribe of people who
are naturally less tribal yeah
and they tend to traffic
highly
on ideas
and respond to logic and
reason or what we perceive to be a
logical reason
a stat you put out a lot is like of
course right now 62 percent of people
believe that duopoly isn't working for
americans and it feels like the perfect
decade for
to
act on this but how do we make the
messaging compelling knowing human
nature and knowing the tribalism aspect
of there needs to be some tension
um in terms of like really to cause an
uprising and make this happen how do you
think the effective messaging should be
though yeah so so that this is something
that uh we're going to be spending a lot
of time on the next number of days even
yes um to center on a message that is
comprehensible and catchy yup and
someone will just like click and be like
okay i know what what what these folks
are about easy and i'm into it i'm
excited about it so that's a particular
challenge if you're going to try and do
something that's big tent third party
which is what we're trying to build here
there's a trap associated with where
with what we're trying to build right
now it's called the mushy middle
is that interesting interesting
yeah is that like this size for this so
that's for that it's like where for
getting along yeah yeah you know where
for
logic and reason compromise fact-based
governance yeah even if it's not getting
along sometimes that messaging isn't com
like it is compelling for a lot it is
more so yeah like we are for logic and
reason like let's move away from this
because it is not that yeah we're for
getting stuff done and by the way the
system's not going to get anything done
well the forward party launched with a
particular set of principles
and we're going to be re-examining the
messaging around them over the next
number of
days to try and see if we can strike the
right chord
so one possibility example would be
like you know get corporate money out of
politics yeah because people
instinctively sense that both major
parties are kind of in the pocket of
various companies uh so that that has
like a concrete dimension and it's like
okay i i kind of know what these folks
are about so that's one possibility
there are others you talked about this
actually in your most recent podcast
interview and i found it fascinating the
way so everything is becoming globalized
now everything's becoming universal and
i feel like by the end of this decade
we're going to look at this
u.s centric fighting power between
people as just like child's play like
why did we waste so much time on that
when there are much broader issues that
we have to get into and they are
worldwide not just within a country we
need to focus like on our humanity and
worldwide collaboration and can you
explain why this is i want people to
watch that episode because i found it
very important yeah so i interviewed ian
bremmer about his new book the power of
crisis and he's centered on three things
that are massive issues facing the
entire human race yeah um so the first
is future pandemics makes sense the
second is climate change obvious then
the third one less obvious to folks is
disruptive tech including ai and yet a
very specific example that i think is
what caught your attention which is that
as soon as a country
announces that it is cracked quantum
computing then it renders uh every other
country's
attempts to safeguard their information
obsolete and so you could crash anyone's
financial system you could do whatever
you want if you have quantum computing
before anyone else and so as soon as
someone says hey i have quantum
computing
then another country might say oh i
guess i have to
nuke you because
you can essentially nuke me anytime you
want now that you can crack every code i
have right now
quantum computing is being developed in
secret in various labs
and
[Music]
what
he'd want us to do is have some kind of
global agreement where it's like look
we're all working on quantum computing
whoever gets there yep like you know
let's agree that we're not going to use
it to try to take over the world and
that's real now you know like china
certainly is
uh investing
billions probably tens of billions on ai
and this sort of effort
so
that was one thing that he described he
also described the fact that we have
criminal actors or rogue states or
terrorist
organizations who will have access to
weaponized ai
and some cyber warfare tools that will
potentially
introduce
like completely different
vulnerabilities uh into systems where if
you have
countries you worry about another big
country it's like actually all you need
is like a group of crazy people in this
ai that can disrupt your infrastructure
so
i mean you know it's it's obviously some
pretty dark stuff that ian is projecting
it's all perfectly sensible though
uh and so
he's he wants us to get ahead of it by
uh encouraging global cooperation on
something like a world data organization
which if you're a really eagle-eyed yang
gang like you remember i actually uh
said that in one of the debates um and i
said that because ian suggested to me
[Laughter]
because you're messaging around ubi and
i first came across your videos i
believe it was like early 2019 right
before you had been on rogan a lot of
the messaging was targeted towards jobs
like manufacturing jobs truck drivers
cashiers ones jobs that a lot of
americans have the vast majority of them
do what i found interesting so as a
reminder people i like create a lot of
content um online around tech and
digital culture because of this i've
been getting like outreach from
a lot of companies that have artificial
intelligence as their foundation within
their products and a lot of these are
creative products you know and i knew ai
was getting in you know more creative
jobs but it's actually like
wowed me so whether it's copywriting of
just putting in a few words that i want
a piece of writing to be about and it
feeding me back a two-page essay fully
about it i'm like the new natural
language ai engine is
indistinguishable from a human writer
faster more powerful it's crazy you can
have a text conversation with them it's
where it's a human being and it's just
gonna get better and there's definitely
uses to this creative text you know
copywriting is very tedious i
experienced that in my everyday life
that's super helpful in terms of saving
time
um when you're kind of conceptualizing
an idea i'm not a super artistic person
when it comes to drawing so whether it's
like maybe an idea i have for yeah like
a creative purpose and i can type some
words and it can feed that back to me
like super yeah that's super powerful so
like to think of it all as doom and
gloom i'm like definitely trying not to
because there are it's definitely time
savers but thinking of how our
relationship is going to move forward
with it and especially with work and
like as i've gotten more into the
workforce and yeah have realized the
importance of still having set meetings
within certain times every week to help
me
just stay on track of all these
different things like how our
relationship is going to change with
this stuff well this is one of the
things they talk about the war on normal
people
where it's like we're all
now competing against machines in
various ways we've internalized the
market logic even what you just
described it's like you keep myself on
track i'm going to like make sure that
you know
which i'm that is true which i'm for on
a human level
you know like i'm i'm like you know i
want to kick ass as much as the next
person but you have to realize it's like
look we're going to lose this particular
race and so like we have to get with the
program and figure out what like the new
world's going to look like i mean
there's no time to waste
but it does hinge upon us
restoring a functioning uh political
system
i mean that's one of the things that's
been you know it's been interesting for
me so like i
ran for president had this very very
significant and i actually read the war
on normal people myself love that like
uh you know
reread it and the problem's freaking
real and like you know it's like i mean
i don't know if people read the book and
think like oh this is alarmist or
whatnot but i mean like half the stuff's
unfolding in front of us
um and then now i'm i i feel like okay
like now i need to try and restore the
political process to a point where we
can actually get something done and i do
see a path there i mean i'm i'm really
pumped about it um but it it does make
it
seem
like the
problems that i set out to solve it's
like look i'm going to put you aside for
a minute because i can't solve you until
i solve this other problem so let me
solve this other problem then i'll
return to like the
the these huge problems that by the way
are getting worse and one of them is
that the way tech so you know i live in
new york city and i remember ad agencies
and yeah these ad agencies have gotten
completely
like upended by tech now because it's
like you know i don't need you you to
produce copy because you can just
produce 100 ads and then whichever one
performs best elevate that so like
you're out of the way and then
like this you know they have these
creative fields that are all just going
to get usurped by tech over time
yeah i mean it's already happening so
getting it we were just talking about
how we need very
simplistic concise messaging that people
really understand easily and the
independent political movement is deeply
important to me and i want people to
fully understand what ford represents
because of this because during the
presidential election you were strongly
tied to ubi and that was an easy mind
connection for people like andrew yang
ubi you know they learned the basics of
ubi as well but i i would love to go
through like the six core principles of
the forward party and you just give like
a quick one to two sentence explanation
of each because i think that will be
really just like key messaging for
people to have right now sure let's do
it very happy dude so i know the big
picture i think if i were to describe
the the forward party
uh in
one word it's uh unbought i mean right
now like we are truly like the scrappy
underdogs and people are like oh like
what you know um like what are you gonna
do when like the the companies want to
give you money it's like no sane company
wants to give us money because we don't
control a damn thing you know
they're just gonna pump billions of
dollars at the yeah the other guys so
we're the the genuine people-powered
uh political revolution that a lot of
people know is necessary and that we
want to deliver from outside the system
to go in and change the system so a
summary would be unbought but the
principles you're describing universal
basic income
uh fact-based governance which is like
look we just need to figure out the
baselines are and then try and drive
towards them and i became very
excited about effective altruism which
is essentially like the same thing
philanthropically it's like look let's
try and figure out what's going to make
a difference and drive results um so
looking for government that revolves
around measurements truly like you have
to agree on a baseline human-centered
economy which is like we should be the
point of the economy and like right now
you see it where financial measurements
will continue
getting better while while we don't
so so we could
change that up and one question about
that so were three three of six
principles in when it comes to
human-centered economy on the website i
think it's stated as like human-centered
capitalism what do you say to people who
kind of refute like those two can't live
together in terms of being a
capitalistic society being
human-centered how do you feel about
that
um
oh you know it's nomenclature you know
it's like i think if you want
uh to have our health and mental health
and our kids success rate be an
important measurement for society
doesn't matter in my mind if you want to
call it human-centered economy or
human-centered capitalism i agree
uh yeah grace intolerance which is like
look we can uh disagree on various
things and you know it's okay
um which i'm gonna suggest is kind of an
important thing nowadays for sure
no arguing um modern and effective
government so much right now is just
like stuff doesn't not working well i
mean we can't find baby formula in like
the richest country the history of the
world does that make any sense to
anybody you know it's like
let's
and and right now like neither party
really is responsible for trying to make
things work better they're just like ah
you know what are you gonna do both the
other side and and you know it is true
like you know at this point
one one party seems almost
anti-government um but but the the
democratic party often seems more intent
on messaging than on performance you
know i think there are a lot of
independents and republicans are like
look if we're gonna spend the money we
should try and spend it on stuff that
works
of course
uh and then bring home what's number six
number six ranked choice voting and open
primaries oh my gosh i freaking buried
the lead
you buried the
top the lead look at that
so uh open primaries and ranked choice
voting so that anyone can compete anyone
can run you can vote for people of any
party
uh to to make it so that you have a
truly dynamic multi-party system
uh i think that we're in for an historic
realignment really quickly because
people are so fed up if it really does
end up being trump versus biden which by
the way i think it will i think trump
declares in october so he can take
credit for the midterms how boring and
then early next year joe biden says i
will stand to run against trump because
he sees it as his god-given mission to
defeat trump uh and then 58 of americans
will be like i cannot believe we're
running these two dudes again who are
four years older this cannot be the two
best choices in a country of 330 million
please someone give me anyone else
uh and then the forward party will be
there being like interesting you want
you want another choice like maybe we
can
um help drum up some candidates um so i
i think this stuff's going to be
relevant and have a ton of wind at its
back uh pretty freaking quick 100 and
then a question i have for um an
effective and modern government you made
this point i think when you were on like
the h3 podcast maybe like two years ago
how exactly like how many decades it's
estimated that the government is behind
on like how they utilize tech
what was that number
i just remember
we're
26 years out of date um because we got
rid of the office of technology
assessment in the mid-90s
uh and so this is a really good timing
right
uh it was to save money good times in
the
that that 83. now we have to save
humanity
seriously
that's so dumb so
but that that's again an example of the
fact that government doesn't need to
perform well in a two-party system for
people to hold onto power
you know i mean if we did everything
right this would still be a very very
difficult time but if we don't come
together meaningfully it's going to be
disastrous on a scale that i think most
people are just now waking up to so as a
reminder and ending with this the six
core principles of the forward party the
og universal basic income human-centered
economy ranked choice voting and open
primaries an effective and modern
government fact-based governance grace
intolerance love it all i think it's
important to share i will say that we're
probably going to be messaging them in
some snappier way yes because these six
core principles i think appeal to the
logical among us so we're going to try
and get a couple of the illogical people
on board
[Laughter]
we need you
okay love it all right thanks andrew i
love this conversation and thanks
everyone for listening thanks jules
[Music]
you